oh my goodness my goodness my goodness
Thank You president Orrin good afternoon
to all of you honored guests most of all
to the class of 2014 and to all of you
assembled here on this solemn and yet
this happy occasion speaking here at
Hillsdale seems to me to be something of
a dream a dream in the first place
because I have the great honor of
speaking here at this commencement and a
dream in the second place because
Hillsdale exists having graduated Yale
as you've heard you may imagine I'm not
used to the idea of a college that
espouses conservatism it seems to me too
good to be true and yet here we are so
let me say up front that I thank God for
this place and I thank God for all
that's been taught here and accomplished
here for the great cause of freedom as
you've heard my mother and father came
from Greece and Germany respectively in
the mid 50's they met in an English
class not an English literature class a
class where you learn to speak English
in New York City in 1956 I live in New
York now with my wife and our daughter
my parents came from war-torn Europe and
knew that America was a place that
promised opportunity that stood for
something for liberty and justice my
mother lived under communism in East
Germany my father lived in Greece when
the Communists were trying to take
control of that country so they loved
America and raised my brother and me to
love it when I grew up my father admired
William F Buckley 's newspaper columns
and always told me how he was learning
new vocabulary in reading them I
actually had the great honor of meeting
Buckley some years ago and I had myself
just learned the word lapidary from
reading his books I had the thrill of
being at one of the last tapings of
firing line
and buckley used that word in talking to
Henry Kissinger and I was tremendously
entertained to see dr. Kissinger
flustered obviously having no idea what
it meant but I'm getting ahead of myself
so yes I grew up hearing my father
admire Buckley and Reagan and Nixon and
I admired them too until I attended Yale
University that's because no sooner had
I arrived there then I realized that the
cool people at Yale thought
conservatives were fascists and I'm
ashamed to say that over time I began to
adopt their thinking I'm particularly
ashamed of something that happened in my
senior year I remember a friend's sister
had spent a semester in the Soviet Union
that was the chic thing to do for
students in 1983 and she returned with
tons of propaganda posters which many of
us predictably and stupidly posted in
our dorm rooms I will never forget when
my father came to visit my dorm room and
saw a poster of Lenin that his son had
put up he said to me Erik I have a favor
to ask you
he said I would like you to take that
poster down imagine the man who was
working a very difficult job in order to
pay for my Yale tuition saying it that
graciously suddenly It was as if scales
had fallen from my eyes I realized I
betrayed my father and my mother and my
country and my values I'd fallen into
that way of thinking of course I took
the poster down and now I speak of it
with the greatest shame imaginable but
such was the atmosphere at Yale then I
know it is the same or worse now but
it's been that for a long time that way
speaking of Buckley his book God and man
at Yale published in 51 talks about the
wildly leftist and anti-christian
atmosphere at Yale when he was a student
there in the late 1940s these things
have Dee
brutes though I took the poster down
that day I'm afraid I did not change my
politics I graduated in 1984 I wanted to
become a writer how to do that exactly
well what I did was I floundered and
then I drifted then I floundered some
more and then I drifted and floundered
simultaneously now if you do that by the
way there is only one thing that can
happen you will inevitably move back in
with your parents it's precisely what I
did and I do not recommend it especially
if your parents are European immigrants
who've worked especially hard to put you
through a college like Yale so that year
living with them was an awful year but
something happened to me as a result
which I will cherish forever
I was solo during that year
that I was suddenly open to new ideas
eventually many conversations with a
conservative Christian friend led me to
wonder if maybe I'd had a few things
wrong after about a year of these
conversations I had what people might
call a bona fide conversion experience
it was dramatic and life-changing
there's a video at my website it's just
my name Eric Metaxas dot-com where I
tell the story and trust me it is an
extraordinary story if not mind-blowing
watch it and you can decide for yourself
exactly what happened so suddenly I
believed in God and a lot of things
changed for one thing my politics began
to shift I cringed to admit publicly
still having voted for Jesse Jackson in
the Democratic primaries a few months
later and then for Dukakis in the
general election I was about to duck
thank you
but shortly after that I saw the light
and I'm very proud to say I've been a
dyed-in-the-wool conservative ever since
for example I have now spoken at CPAC
three times but what exactly is this
link between my newfound faith and the
God of the Bible and my conservatism
well of course I'm not alone in linking
them Buckley was it about Christian and
of course God in man at Yale details the
collusion between leftist political
ideology and materialistic atheism at
Yale as I've said and I'm sure I don't
need to tell you of their strong
historical alliance in communist nations
you probably know that justices Roberts
Scalia and Thomas are devout Christians
Reagan's faith was deep and I made a
note to myself here
not to mention Jimmy Carter I can't
believe I just did that I've sort of
blown my whole thesis can we get rid of
that in post gonna nod you you're the
man thank you thank you where was I oh
yes the inextricable intertwining of
faith and American liberty yes well in
all seriousness let me first of all say
that real faith is never something that
can be forced by the state it's
something that either can be encouraged
and smiled upon or discouraged and
frowned upon or simply crushed as it has
been in every communist country but it's
especially worth considering the
historical place of faith in America
precisely because it has under the
current administration come under
unprecedented threat religious freedom
which was at the very heart of the
founders vision for America cannot be
compromised without all of our liberties
being compromised in America as we know
her being redefined into non-existence
so let's rehearse the basics briefly
most of you already know this but for
any who do not a Hillsdale education
would of course be incomplete without it
and your wise leaders in bringing you
here have caught you just in time you
cannot leave this place without grasping
this foundational tenets of American
Burtie so the first stroke in our brief
narrative must begin before our founding
when our forefathers landed at Plymouth
having suffered tremendous religious
persecution some years before they came
here specifically so they could believe
and worship as they wished they landed
here for religious freedom we leap ahead
to the founders who understood the role
of religious freedom in writing our
constitution they said the government
must not establish a religion this did
not mean the government was anti
religion on the contrary they wish to
protect religion from all state
intervention and just as the state must
not pick winners in the economic sphere
it must not pick winners in the sphere
of religion it must keep back and let
the people decide let the free market of
ideas do its work the people would
decide with no help or hindrance from
government thank you very much but
there's more to what the founders had in
mind than the Establishment Clause they
talked also of the free exercise of
religion so let anyone using those
weasel words freedom of worship know
that they have freedom of worship in
China and it is meaningless and it is
vile freedom of worship says you may do
what you like in that building on Sunday
mornings or whenever you like
but when you come out you will bow to
the secular orthodoxy of the state that
is the antithesis of what the founders
meant in guaranteeing freedom of
religion they knew that a robust
exercise of religion was necessary for
America to survive that people
exercising their religious convictions
was vital to the success of this fragile
experiment in Liberty called America now
here's something that may surprise you
my dear friend oz Guinness talks about
what the founders called the Golden
Triangle of freedom when I first heard
of the Golden Triangle of freedom I was
ashamed to admit I knew nothing about it
by the way he spoke brilliantly at
Socrates in the city event in New York
City on this subject and I urge you to
go to Socrates in the city comm to watch
that speech it is a pair Asian worthy of
demosthenes or Cicero or Churchill if I
may say so or you can get his book of
free people suicide on this subject it
is simply magnificent in that book he
explains the founders idea of the Golden
Triangle of freedom it's simply that
freedom requires virtue virtue requires
faith faith requires freedom and freedom
requires virtue and round and round it
goes
so what does this mean why does freedom
require virtue what are the founders
mean well because American freedom means
self-government not government by the
elites but government by the people so
how are the people to govern themselves
if they have no virtue if we have no
virtue won't we just vote to line our
own pockets and elect people who will
give us what we want what about actual
stealing isn't it obvious that the more
virtuous of people is the fewer
policemen we need virtuous people police
themselves even the Constitution even
the Constitution is not sufficient by
itself we need self-governing people
virtuous citizens who govern themselves
because they believe it is the right
thing to do and so they do it freely
John Adams of course famously said our
government was not armed with power
sufficient to contend with human
passions unbridled by morality and
religion avarice ambition etc would
break the strongest chords of our
constitution as a whale goes through a
net our Constitution he declared was
made only for a moral and religious
people it is wholly inadequate to the
government of any other so freedom
requires virtue what of the second leg
of the triangle virtue requires religion
well certainly not always there are many
people who are religious and corrupt
many who have no religion and who are
virtuous but generally speaking those
who acknowledge a higher power and the
laws of
that higher power tend to be more
virtuous than those who do not than
those who believe they can themselves
make whatever laws they like and who are
beholden to no one in his farewell
address General Washington said of all
the dispositions and habits which lead
to political prosperity religion and
morality are indispensable supports in
that same address this greatest of all
Americans said and led us with caution
indulge the supposition that morality
can be maintained without religion John
Adams in 1790 commenting on the French
Revolution said I know not what to make
of a republic of 30 million atheists to
him it was destined by its very nature
to fail and he said as much and of
course it did so freedom requires virtue
virtue requires religion and then the
third leg' religion requires freedom how
then does religion require freedom well
this is the simplest of all to
understand today we need only consider
the Middle East or God helped them North
Korea religion is the most fragile of
all freedoms and that's because it is
the most threatening to those in power
as I tell in my book about Dietrich
Bonhoeffer Hitler despised the
Christians in Germany who actually
wanted to live out their faith those who
merely went to church and kept their
faith to themselves were no threat but
Bonhoeffer and niemoller and all those
who took their faith seriously were a
tremendous threat and he knew it state
power fears those who wish to actually
exercise their faith and let me add that
if one is not exercising one's faith
perhaps that's because one actually has
none when faith becomes a private thing
a thing that has not lived out in action
it is no faith at all and the founders
knew this
religious liberty and the free exercise
of faith was at the heart of the
American experiment and we've had so
much religious freedom in this nation
that we've really forgotten what it is
just as the fish hardly knows what water
is it has been everywhere and in such
great abundance that we've taken it for
granted before we close let me clarify
something a free-market is of course
also indispensable to true liberty but
to those who suppose it's efficient let
me remind you that the invisible hand of
the market gives consumers what they
want and if they're not virtuous
consumers and merely want better and
cheaper pornography and drugs that is
what the market will deliver the market
will give us what we want not what is
good for us unless what we want is what
is good for us and for that one requires
a virtuous people and what about
democracy and free elections of course
this is also indispensable to true
Liberty but any idea that this can exist
apart from these other things any idea
that freedom is innate is naive I won't
tell you what that idea has cost us in
American blood and treasure democracy
and Liberty can only flourish when
virtue has been inculcated into the
people who vote when they are first
prepared for that Liberty as by God's
grace we were prepared in 1776 as I tell
in my book on Bonhoeffer when their
monarchy was dissolved and democracy was
forced upon Germany following World War
1 Germans hated it and it did not work
and then they democratically elected
Nazis into the Reichstag in such numbers
that Hitler was catapulted into the
chancellorship so yes democracy by
itself can lead to Hitler in Egypt it
led recently to the Muslim Brotherhood
taking over until the anti-democratic
forces of the military
stepped in Oh irony so let's resurrect
this idea of the founders the Golden
Triangle of freedom we must remember
that they instituted that famous wall of
separation between church and state to
protect the church from the interference
of the state for liberty to flourish the
church and faith must flourish or the
whole thing falls from the sky like
Icarus let's go one final step further
for a long time for the time that we as
a nation were ascending to greatness the
story we told ourselves was that we were
uniquely chosen by God Abraham Lincoln
called us the almost chosen people this
was not a jingoistic manifest destiny
variety of cried no it was a holy burden
to be chosen to shine the light of
liberty as a beacon to the whole world
as a symbol of hope Lincoln understood
that we were chosen by God to represent
God and God's purposes in history and he
was very explicit about that indeed on
April 30th 1863 the great Emancipator
issued a proclamation calling the nation
to play a prayer let me quote from it as
I close the proclamation says whereas
the Senate of the United States devoutly
recognizing the supreme authority and
just government of Almighty God in all
the affairs of men and of Nations has by
a resolution requested the President to
designate and set apart a day for
National Prayer Lincoln said it is the
duty of Nations as well as of men to own
their dependence upon the overruling
power of God and to recognize the
sublime truth announced in the Holy
Scriptures and proven by all history
that those nations only are blessed
whose God is the Lord
Lincoln said we have been the recipients
of the choicest bounties of heaven
we have been preserved these many years
in peace and prosperity we have grown in
numbers wealth and power as no other
nation has ever grown but we have
forgotten God we have forgotten the
gracious hand which preserved us in
peace and multiplied and enriched and
strengthened us and we have veinly
imagined in the deceitfulness of our
hearts that all these blessings were
produced by some superior wisdom and
virtue of our own intoxicated with
unbroken success we have become too
self-sufficient to feel the necessity of
redeeming and preserving grace to proud
to pray to the God that made us those
are the words of Abraham Lincoln so yes
let us heed that dire warning and let us
understand what the founders understood
and what Abraham Lincoln understood that
if we push God out of American public
life we you and I in our silence and
ignorance will be complicit in
extinguishing the hope of the world if
America forgets God we will kill what
Lincoln called the last best hope of
Earth
god forbid thank you very much god bless
you and God bless america
thank you